we're we're trying to get at the root
cause why are men in such crisis I mean
the stats are like only 40 go to college
so they're losing out to women there in
a big way and women with degrees don't
marry men who don't have degrees so
[Laughter]
that's right great you'll be lonely
forever aren't you why are you cheering
that that's not I didn't tell my wife
they don't they don't marry as much
which I think is great but other people
think that's a terrible thing okay uh
people do like a mate whatever that's
whatever you blow your boat floats by
um but there is something going on I
mean mass shootings is a uniquely male
crime it's always because some dude in
Buffalo you know had somebody swipe left
on him too much that I mean I feel like
that's what's going on here is is a lot
of
sort of maleness coming to the fore and
announcing itself in violence and racism
and hatred because they're lonely and
lost they feel that they are not useful
in society the most sense how did we get
there the most unstable nations in the
world have one thing in common and that
is they have too many lonely broke and
Alone Men it's the most dangerous person
in the world someone Rusty wasn't
attacked because of the fatwa he was
attacked because a guy was living in his
mother's basement we have we have a
crisis among young men and it starts at
a young age young men are twice as
likely on a behavior-adjusted basis to
be suspended seven in ten high school
valedictorians or women for every one
female for every two female graduates
from college the next five years you
only have one the scariest stat walking
down the Avenue that is America only one
in three men under the age of 30 have
had sex in the last year and you hear
sex and your brain fires but the bottom
line is it's a key step to the elemental
Foundation of any society and that is
relationships men young men aren't
attaching to work they aren't attaching
to women they aren't attaching to
schools we are producing too many of the
most dangerous person in society and we
are losing out on a key we're not going
to have kids we're not going to have a
productive Society we're gonna have more
violence and also we're going to have a
society that does not value uh young men
and they do not young men are different
they develop later and by the way if
you're a young man this work from home
thing is a disaster they need young men
young men
young men need guard rails they need to
know how to read a room they need to put
on a clean shirt they know not to get
high or drink too much during the week
and then get into the office the next
day we have a crisis among young men it
is it is it is it is one of the most in
my view one of the most dangerous things
in our society and
where do you put the phone
in this equation because I put it high
up because thank you
because
because I was reading recently a Tinder
two to one male to female
oh what no it's just a startling
statistic yeah right but why is it
startling I mean it sounds like a great
idea oh I can just order women like I do
a pizza on my phone I think I'll have
the Kelly today
except when you when you go on it it
weeds out the people who aren't the best
looking I think because it you know it
used to be go to a bar okay maybe it was
potluck but you have to be able to learn
to talk to a woman you they I don't
think how to talk to a woman anymore
because it's just on the phone it's just
like what's up
yeah
and then
you know what's up and send a picture of
your penis like that's gonna work
sometimes so you sometimes you you asked
about the phone simply put it's a
disaster whenever technology comes into
an industry consolidates it mating has
been Consolidated in the worst way 50
men on Tinder 50 women 46 of the women
show all of their attention to just four
men leaving 46 men
pursuing just four women if if mating
was a country it would be more unequal
than Venezuela we have huge mating
inequality and here's the problem when
people don't get together and there's no
pheromones and there's no vibe women and
we don't like to say this on the left
primarily try and make very quick
assumptions about this individual's
ability to Garner resources in the
future so what you have is this
concentration of interest and you're
ending up with Porsche polygamy where 10
of the men get 90 percent of the
attention which is not lead to good
behavior or form long-term relationships
e-commerce was disastrous for retail
social media was disastrous for
everybody online dating is disastrous
for mating and for men it's terrible